[Music]
[Applause]
I'd be seeing you in all the old
familiar places then this heart of mine
embraces Oh day
I love it Tony Lane Casserly I'm so
excited to have you on the show again
you are amazingly talented across Boise
you ever worked it so well like that's
beautiful I love it it's amazing it is
it's so cool it's so cool that you can
sing because the voice is right here
with us all the time we don't need
another instrument a hundred percent and
voice can also be used for energetic
clearing finding harmony and resonance I
think you're more in tune as you move
through life if you have a background
whether that background is in music
sports reading science I think if you
have the ability to tune into something
you know because people talk about
singing like it's this process of like
expression like I'm gonna do this big
operatic like but it's not when you
actually sing you are tuning into
empathetic experience because when I
practice a song I grew up doing this and
when I would grow up performing I didn't
think that the show was me because it
wasn't every show was different because
I could feel the audience and there are
different times where people would want
something different for me you practice
the song a hundred thousand times so
that you know it so that when you
perform you're not the one up there
performing it's you channeling the
experiences from every person around you
through you and when you channel those
experiences then you're actually giving
someone a performance otherwise it's
it's just I mean it's just sound there's
nothing like and that's why performance
is so important even to experience life
for you to be a part of that creative
process because the audience is just as
much a part of the creative process as
the artist who's on stage performing the
work your your
you're you're delivering an experience
for an audience and your your your
energetically playing with what's
present there with the audience this
isn't about just whatever is there
whatever you want to do this is based on
what the experience is calling in the
moment for the audience and I think
that's same thing applies medians as
well for sure anyone who's on stage
anyone who's on stage even even the
lectures etc yeah very interesting way
to put it and there's so cool you can go
all the way to your opera voice - you're
more like the jazzier voice it's just
it's cool to be able to do that I got to
work my voice more alright yeah everyone
hey pay attention you're gonna hear me
singing in a year we'll see about that
but it's actually the key thing more
than anything is that and it's it's
actually about a level of empathy in the
harmonics of everything that is because
when you're feeling sometimes you can
even um cleanse someone yeah
and they're filled because you can feel
sometimes I'm around someone it's kind
of like why I'm so I think sensitive
because sometimes I'll be around people
and I'm like whoa I'm like I can just
look through them and then in looking
through them I can surface and presents
things that people are like man I've
been struggling with that problem for
the last 15 years and I no one no one
has ever
I haven't actually spoken about this I
actually had recently as someone say you
know I haven't spoken to anyone about
this in five years and I've known you
for 30 minutes and you didn't literally
touch this it's like I can find the
tonal resonance and then you can just
get that pain out and like release it
and that's actually what for me music
always was is it it was expression and
empathy but it was also actually an
energetic cleansing it was calibrating
my field harmonics to release from
stored energy but it's actually what you
need people think that like having a
spiritual practice is like oh I meditate
but part of what you actually need to do
is is cleansing your field happens in
made if
waise maybe maybe running is your
spiritual practice but you need to move
you need to move and cleanse your energy
and whether that's through moving sounds
through your body moving the ocean and
the Sun through your body when you surf
whether that's to moving other people
through your body when you perform right
you need to have something that can that
can both cleanse your field and
hopefully in turn can help provide a
greater resonance for more people to to
get in touch with their heart again
because that's what people lose that
that gift connects people with it brings
you back to your heart and if you're not
living there just check yourself even
right now like do a five-four
three-two-one like can I feel myself and
can I feel where my energy is that can I
even can I feel my own heart and if I
don't what am i hiding from if there's a
place where I don't feel connected or
where I feel overly connected or where I
feel a block even where I feel pain or a
joy what is present for me in this
moment because that is all that is is
this moment now in the midst of
everything else that exists the
importance of being presence remains
because this your your field right now
your energetics your harmonics this is
actually structuring the evolution of
your entire conscious pathway and what
is in you they say the law of attraction
is like you can just think things into
existence but it's also a process of can
you harmonize with someone's energy
mm-hmm and can you reach harmonic
resonance because if you can do that
then you actually have the power to let
the world move through you but if you're
blocked yeah that's what you'll
experience in life you'll experience
that your life is like a series of
roadblocks and you're like like why do I
keep why do I keep going through this
challenge I don't I don't want to have
to deal with this or I don't have to be
around this or my but what is really the
problem it's not that you're not a
victim okay
you get out victim consciousness is like
here okay you got to get out of that
that level it's like no it's actually
that you have to recalibrate yourself
you're experiencing that because your
body you are asking yourself to
experience that that's the only reason
why and it might not even be the highest
version of you but you're experiencing
what you're experiencing because of the
way that you presents yourself and if
you don't then what flows through your
life and what throws through your what
flows through your fueled of illusions
is is directly and inherently based on
the harmonics of what exists in you so I
mean change your harmonics change your
life yeah there's there's a huge reason
to sing to learn how to sing you get to
carry it with you and then also there's
this energetics there's this harmonics
that you speak of that the heart every
time it beats every second like you got
us to feel our hearts that that's it's a
muscle that we have to train to be able
to tune in word and feel our heartbeat
and so when you sit when you sing you're
you're you're unleashing of vibration
throughout your being and necklace it's
interesting that you mentioned that you
could help someone else with a blockage
that they have through your voice
because you know when you sing the Ron
and I in here we were like whoa like
this feels amazing there's something
about it it's like when you play an
instrument similarly if you tuned into
the instrument you just kind of melt you
know in essence it's it's so profoundly
important for us to care more about that
so Tony Lancaster really you guys can
watch episode that we had together
earlier this year so all known as the
the Joan of Arc of blockchain blockchain
advocate a digital currency advocate and
speaker across the world spends most of
her time in a briefcase now suitcase
suitcase
yes briefcase would be too small for
Tunisia I could probably like wear
doing the contortion stuff so yeah
trying to get to a briefcase level but
that really takes some fixing skills so
lots of speaking around the world
teaching people about decentralization
especially about the importance of
decentralization in governance and as we
make a big transition to having more
effective protocols for humanity to
flourish more easily yeah and so that's
been with culture with coin Telegraph
with cos there's a bunch of different
things here but all these links are in
the bio go check out Tony's work in more
detail so we have a couple topics that
we want to talk about today in our
second episode together
besides harmonics and yes that was so
fun that was so fun it was a great way
to intrude so that was a second time
we've intro'd with music we had Paul let
intro intro and outro with guitar we
would love for you to outro with your
voice as well that would be awesome ok
let's talk about so we have infinite
economy is something that we want to
talk about we also want to talk about
this spiritual bypass yeah I think let's
let's start off with because you just
came in with the spiritual bypass for me
you see how your body is in contract
yeah I did oh I was watching you do that
earlier we were talking about it like
and that's even being that's why I mean
about presencing it's like noticing
where like when someone says something
rather than reacting like noticing oh
like where does that sit am I am I
literally like crunched over like where
does that sit in my body because then
you'll be able to presence your feeling
before you react and that level of
consciousness is actually something that
it's really I think like just
maintenance for healthful behavior so
you can control rather than responding
like oh i'm so triggered you can present
you o be like ooh wow like that makes me
just go and contract rather than just
like responding like being the response
that you feel presence you're feeling
and then respond yeah good that's so
good that that's that's that's a major
principle of the meditative philosophy
and the mindful principles
spend more time cognizing and feeling
rather than reacting right away oh but
it's muscle again it's something that
has to be trained it's not just though
I'm gonna intellectualize this no it's
an actual thing yeah okay it's holiday
time people holiday time holiday time
means you are gonna be passing time with
your family you'll be passing time with
these triggers and so this is the this
is the best time right now over holiday
time to practice not getting triggered
rather to be calm feel and then react
with a question why does somebody feel
the way I do anyway and compassion and
compassion especially you know it's
family yeah for sure for sure for sure
all right
so spiritual bypassing yeah let's
because this it's interesting we we have
done two shows with Bernard Gunther now
also we just did a video on on with us
not being ready for transhumanism and
that's one of the thesis is that that
Bernard rates bond that we care about
because we don't think we understand
ourselves well enough yet to to merge
with machines and so in Tony Tony
totally called that calls this the
spiritual bypassing I was like whoa
that's a really good way to put it so
teach us about why you call a spiritual
bypass so I work with indigenous nations
and the spiritual bypass is based like
this whole subculture of people who are
like yeah like are you guys like gonna
go do ayahuasca this weekend like I
mixed Oh into mushrooms like I like love
like all of these like super like
ibogaine yeah I meant combo with all my
scars and it's basically a group of
people that use spiritual work as social
validation without actually doing the
work so they're like yeah I've done
ayahuasca like 50 times and then you're
like really because it seems like you're
still like it seems like you're so like
also like addicted to ketamine and like
really deeply unconscious about where
you're at in your life and like doing
things that are pretty harmful to
yourself and others like so it doesn't
really seem like you've you might have
like taken the drug but you haven't
the medicine and so spiritual bypassing
is like this whole subculture of people
that's on fire right now it for sure
just letting you know it's like really
like that I felt a big forget when you
were speaking that way about I because I
haven't met people like this yeah I've
heard I've gotten close like the people
that kind of get close that but I mean
the way you're saying it right now is
really because this is a sacred thing
actually communing with the infinite
exactly exactly and you know but you
know what's real is that if you're not
at that level
spirits are kind of like they don't they
can't do the work like enough the thing
is that if you're basically not making
space for the work to be done because
you're like afraid of facing the stuff
the spirits are like okay well I have
other people to work with like you know
it's about and that's that's the thing
is like for me it's really like this
isn't this is a very this isn't honor
this is a spiritual honor for you to
engage in that medicine in that practice
and my other or the other problem that I
have with it personally is that it's
exploiting indigenous communities by
making it this little fashion drug where
people like oh like we're gonna go do
this in like my New York basement like I
totally got this from like you know like
so I'm like you know I like totally like
all this ayahuasca I'm like so it's like
you know like this guy but like it's
like yeah you know like and not knowing
anything about the medicine the
tradition and the history and so it's
like these these people that are like
wearing the headdresses and I know some
now granted I do know some people that
lead better that are not technically
indigenous but are incredible
priestesses and are incredible at
holding the space for ceremony and
always curious to learn and respect and
honor so there's definitely the other
side to that coin yes then there are
these people that are like you know
wearing the Mohawks to Coachella and
then drinking cups of ayahuasca
interesting like yeah like it's so cool
like a space huh space and that's an
entire subgroup of people
I exactly yeah your face exactly but
that doesn't just happen in a spiritual
work dimension this can also happen in
other way
like you denying your own feelings about
something like a spiritual bypass is
basically a way that you're lying to
yourself and you're denying yourself but
you're saying that you're doing the work
and if you're saying that you're doing
the work but you're lying and denying
the work that needs to be done then
there's a problem you know if you say I
really want to help people that are
living in like I really am extremely
passionate I want to devote my life to
helping people that live in poverty but
then you like go to Whole Foods in by
yourself $700 shoes then it's kind of
like are you really devoting your
resources intensively to that cause or
are you like stepping out and
representing a cause that you're not
actually representing with your actions
so a spiritual bypass is when there's an
in a lack of alignment between what a
between preach and practice mm-hmm or
where someone is at with their where
someone claims to be out with their
values and the system of values that
they actually represent and we're facing
a huge one you're talking about the
Senate individual level which is
extremely important an individual level
and then there's the societal one that's
going on where we're merging with
machines and we don't have any human
ethics built yet so that's the other so
we were talking about this earlier that
there's this level at which I think that
people are all like there's this whole
transhumanist movement but I think we've
actually got that totally wrong I think
science fiction actually got that
totally wrong and I think the next
evolution is something that's gonna make
us more deeply human then deny our
humanity because I think if we continue
to I think most of that theory is based
on the idea that we will continue to
deny our own humanity until we reach a
certain point where we can no longer
continue to be human because we will
have destroyed the planet and we'll have
destroy the earth and will no longer
live on earth and we'll have to migrate
to another planet and they will all
become robots because what this actually
represents is a group of individuals who
structure philosophy based on their fear
of dealing with unconscious traumas that
they or others hold and based on the
idea that as a society we will never
effectively deal with those unconscious
traumas and so we will continue to deny
our ability to Ferdie and we will
continue
deny our ability to be human because
we've so repressed the humanity of
ourselves and of each other that the
denial and the the transhumanism is
easier than becoming more deeply human
but I actually think that's
fundamentally I think that's
fundamentally wrong and I don't think
that's the way things are gonna totally
shake out now will there be the ability
for us to transcend form yeah you we
continue to evolve and we continue to
transcend form but are we gonna
transcend form in a way that makes us
less human no I believe the first thing
we're gonna have to learn and what we
will actually be incentive to learn by
AI and robot labrum more human how to
develop more empathy how to transcend
the traumas of social norms that have
been used to shame oppress guilt fear
judgment violence jealousy that grief I
believe that we will although some of
those things will still exist I believe
that will work first to free ourselves
from our inhumanities before we accept
those in humanities is real I don't
think we can you can't reach a state of
higher consciousness fully living from
the seed of inhumanity I would say
that's not you reaching a state of
higher consciousness that's you reaching
a level of information based on
obtaining based on holding a very low
vibration and that's actually extremely
extremely extremely extremely dangerous
those things you listed those seven or
eight items you listen yeah those are
extremely low vibration and it's a low
vibration to move forth with the
childlike mentality we're like a little
we're like a two-year-old that's given a
in a in a preschool playground that's
given a box of guns and they have to
figure out how to how to work amongst
each other to split up the guns properly
no yeah it's really bad in just in terms
of just the ethics that have evolved on
earth and where we're at and so the way
you the way you talk about what AI and
robots will provide us being that we
become more human I like that a lot yeah
it takes a lot of time
looking inward and I'd be curious to
hear what you how you think that we
would then how a I and robots would help
us to more inward and go through since
yourself work well we need an
intervention
we need an intervention and if we don't
have an intervention then I believe
there will be this world of like people
say like me and like our robot overlords
and I don't believe that is gonna happen
I think that these are largely going to
be seen largely not completely I think
these will largely be seen as beneficial
things however I think that because
humanity's will to survive is so strong
stronger than the thing that we create I
believe that the will of humanity to
survive is stronger than the will of the
systems that we will create because I
don't believe that that inherent process
is something we wouldn't put our
existence at risk to that extreme I
don't believe that we as a human race
would put our existence at risk to that
extreme as you want but I think very
greedy people would well so there's a
level at which to just kind of center
here there's a level at which AI is
making dictatorship more efficient and
that's definitely a conversation that we
can have like how are these tools
actually being used it's kind of like
the conversation about blockchain that
that no one wants to hear that I have to
keep I have a paper actually coming out
from Institute for the future I think
later this month where I talk about this
and it's important to understand the
implications of dictatorships using
blockchain as it is important to
understand the use of blockchain for new
systems of governance for democratic or
be even post post you know positive
democratic system I don't think we've
talked about that so will you teach us
about how blockchain can be used for bad
like for dictators yeah so I mean the
thing is like the first so I am invited
to blotching conferences all over the
world but do you know like what
governments are really making a lot of
hubbub public interest and noise about
using blockchain technology and digital
currency it's dictatorship the largest
ico ever to date is the venezuelan
petrol
damn that is the single largest ICO
that's ever happened and that's a that's
a country that's a national the Petros
in national yeah it's cryptocurrencies
it's back anything the Venezuelan
currency as a crypto backed on oil and
and their economic interests it's a
single largest ICEA that's ever been
done you know why do why are dictators
interested in using blockchain well it's
for pretty much the same reason that
anarchists are because blockchain
eliminates the need for banks it's just
that for anarchists they want to
eliminate the use of government and for
government they want to eliminate the
need for the middleman there did not
government but dictatorship
dictatorships like oh cool we could take
out the bank have a fewer check and
balance and then literally owned the
entire money supply so that any person
who builds an ICO or is an entrepreneur
in our country it is gonna be illegal
for them to use block chains outside of
our national blockchain or if they build
on another currency they're gonna have
to peg it to the crypto whatever
dictator currency the crypto petrol or
whatever now Venezuela's not the the
specific dictatorship that was I can't
reveal that they're not the specific
dictatorship that was talking about
doing that but that is where the that is
where their interests are and that is
where multiple people's interests are I
mean they're because you have the
voluntary anarchists that are trying to
say hey let's all love each other let's
just get rid of the middlemen but let's
I don't know if voluntary anarchists are
saying let's all love each other like
okay let's say the Bennets let's give
them the benefit of doubt just super on
one side is these you know let's all
figure out how to completely understand
ourselves and love each other across the
planet and not have governance blah blah
great and then on the other side of
things there's apparently now is the
wiping out the banks so that you can own
all of the value exchange of a country
and not you're basically wiping out the
checks and balances of your power so
that way there's no one checking and
balancing the power of a dictatorial
government and they get to have full
reigns over if the entrepreneurs don't
want to give a certain amount of
whatever they get they get what
control they want over the entrepreneurs
in that and just a movement of value so
that that's actually what it is holy
[ __ ] yeah that's really [ __ ] up there
is a story written by someone called
Luka Magnotta and but if the thing is
like if we don't understand these
implications now we're not gonna build
better systems we have to understand
that these are the people who are
interested in advance and they're
interested to be more selfish and so we
have to create like Buckminster Fuller
you don't make an existing system
obsolete by trying to fight it that's
happening better system
let's build better economies this is why
the need for innovation and support in
the space is so huge let's build better
economies and I would say the same thing
with AI whoo I mean luckily we have
luckily or challengingly we have other
we have other like giant corporations
that may have stronger interest in
artificial intelligence than then
dictatorships but at the same time it's
a question of yeah there's there's
there's a lot to there's a lot to unpack
there but all we really need to do to be
a success and to continue to merge down
the path of liberty liberation and
freedom is to continue to do what we're
built to do as human beings which is to
create that is how we grow that is how
we survive that is our design that is
how we are built that's how we're made
can you ronke throw up what we have on
NDI because this is what this is so Tony
you can see right here on studio so this
is the good use of blockchain technology
this is good use of decentralization
this is our ability to do things like
make sure that someone who owns property
or land and in a place that doesn't have
the proper the proper protection for
that place can't just have someone that
has a tremendous amount of power just
come in and wipe out that person's land
or property and say that person doesn't
exist they could just kill them etcetera
this is universal citizenship ID
universal love agreements so this is
culture and the link but link is
below for the culture is future telegram
so you can join that and talk about it
more but this is the this is like a
beneficial use of versus dorm horrible
use and so it's good to be able to have
a you know this is what it can be used
for yeah yeah so this is basically a
global jurisdiction and what that means
is that they're the the promise of
blockchain can still become a reality
and that we will shift our relationship
to things like you know if you live in a
in a government that says okay well
guess what being gates punishable by
death
right absolutely not just because you
were born in a different country than me
or someone else doesn't mean that a
person should have more or less rights
merely based on the fact that this is
where your soul came in so it's the
ability for you to say I want to
register my contract outside of a
traditional jurisdiction where my sexual
orientation might be punishable by death
and I want to have this contract
verified by a network of my peers and
perhaps institutions human rights
organizations support groups or
supportive nations who actually want to
give me full ownership over my rights
regardless of where I am and so this is
the ability for you to take ownership
over your agreements outside of the
bounds of a traditional nation as
verified by a network of your peers with
the potential to engage in verification
from institutions who are a part of
participating in protocol creation so
let's talk about how this works because
this is where kind of will segue into
some of these some of the protocol
creations and then I want to also touch
on Universal earned income so what would
it look like for the example where
someone is living somewhere where
they're going to be punished by death
for revealing who they truly are so how
would they use culture and how would
culture help them to be safe being who
they truly are so this is really what
web of trust does so web of trust is our
open source protocol now culture is I've
spent the last five years of my life
trying to figure out how to migrate a
lot of people who need to be migrated
out of a sociopathic
in state model into and I'm not saying
not everyone's trying to do the job
they're definitely a lot of people that
work in government that are trying to do
the job and I'm certainly not personally
attacking I'm certainly not personally
attacking I'm merely saying that the
incentives in the system are geared
toward everything negative about
humanity and I'm certainly I certainly
don't mean that comment to say like
every person who works in government is
that way because there are wonderful
people who work in government but that
the incentives that are baked into the
system are basically exploit our people
and exploit land so we can have more
control it's not based on creating the
greatest good for humans and certain
nations are trying to do that right like
I think a lot of Scandinavia is
Scandinavia and like you know they
probably have the most progressive
models I mean Iceland actually sent
their bankers to jail after the
financial crisis which they're the only
country who did that but there are
people who are really trying to do a
good job and there are people who are
behaving in a way that is you know
attempting to maintain a sense of
responsibility for the power that you're
the influence that you're holding any of
those things and so that is the open
source protocol which is web of trust
which is basically verification through
and anyone can create on that protocol
so if you want to build specifically
like you want to do only one thing and
be one thing you want to do is merit you
can create a whole platform for marriage
using our protocol and our protocol is a
completely open-source piece of software
our business model for the blockchain
Commons is like red hat and then culture
is my for-profit company which is an
interface that I've spent the last five
years basically figuring out that
talking about making a nation on the
blockchain
isn't gonna work because what you have
to deal with is going through the system
if you want to create a nation I mean
look at like Vichy Keita who's probably
the most successful person doing this
today and we're both mutual supporters
of each other and he's doing liberland
and it's basically this marsh in between
Croatia and I'm bad at geography I want
to say it's not Serbia but it's in
between Croatian and other country maybe
it is actually and it was like this
marsh and it was a member of parliament
he was like huh
he's like what
with that Marsh and they're like oh like
it's like it was like a territory they
couldn't agree on what would be done
with it and so it's basically been
unoccupied for a hundred years because
there was a dispute that they never
resolved so they just said well no one
owns that little marsh who cares so he
said oh stuck a flag in it and he's like
liberal and libertarian paradise it's
ours now all the libertarians have
claimed it we're building everything on
the blockchain the vet who's like doing
this like he's going out there every day
he just opened an embassy in San
Francisco like this is his life like he
is the president of a country built on
this marsh that's basically like in this
in this legal in this bat legal battle
um and he's going out there every day it
was like cold liberland li ber LAN D and
so that's going out there every single
day to try and make this in actual
country there they're registering now
people didn't take this seriously until
vit said we're registering businesses on
the blockchain yeah and then people were
like whoa okay you're starting commerce
okay now let's take a look at you of
course yeah of course officially the
Free Republic of liberland is a
micronation claiming an uninhabited
parcel of disputed land on the western
bank of the Danube a oh it is Serbia
between Croatia and Serbia good
geography it was proclaimed on 13th of
April 2015 by check right libertarian
politician and activist vit jedlica yeah
video dica interesting so the official
website oh there's no the board this is
a border dispute and then this little
land in question is seven square
kilometers so a couple like a mile and a
half or two miles less than San
Francisco and square square or ability
they started to take in people out in
boats when they went to liberland
because people were like we're gonna
colonize libertarians were like yeah
America Hannah come on right and they
literally police were boating like if
they caught you on the land it was like
boating you off boating you off boating
you off like there's this extreme
resistance and like yes you might get
recognition from like I work with
indigenous nations so that's different
because there are indigenous nations
have legal recognition but with
something like this it's like going
through the process of making a country
you're basically like okay like I need
like a like fifty trillion dollar
military budget to compete so it's like
yeah yeah well we oh you mean because
people are are trying to no because
they're not gonna recognize you as a
nation unless you come to them with like
trillions of dollars like and even if
you have trillions of dollars like
they're not just gonna let a billionaire
or a trillionaire just say most my flag
in this lame make country there's like
one there are few cases where this has
happened and it's not like a PS just to
clarify but and there are a few cases
where people have like they've taken
this one guy who is just like I'm gonna
live on a boat he got like us like a
giant liner and just took it into the
middle of the ocean and he was like
maritime law I'm a country and they were
kind of like I mean okay you can call
yourself a country because you're not
really posing a threat to anyone and
you're not really doing anything and
like we don't really care but the
process of becoming a country is like
really extreme because guess what else
exists pirates when I tried to do this
there was a pirates are a big deal on
and they're real but that's but that's
the east coast of Africa most that's
we're not talking like fifty miles off
of the Pacific coast of California if
you set up a big boat and start taking
people to like work but no one's gonna
recognize it like that's the difference
is that some of these countries like
island nations that have a lot of excess
capacity could say oh like our
government owns thirty islands here's
one for free which is actually a process
that I was going through with a certain
island nation government and then they
looked at me really seriously and
they're like what are you gonna do about
the pirates and I was like so that's
where I'm sorry so this is an example
where like liberland
could need to deal with people invading
liberal and to pillage the people there
oh I see what you're not only that like
the United Nations getting the unite I
am rooting for this I'm rooting for him
but you have to get member states to
recognize you yeah and and that's a big
political battlefield like the idea for
member member states member states still
haven't recognized indigenous rights the
closest thing we have is in Guatemala
Guatemala is the first country
to have indigenous representation
actually structured in their government
and there's a film about that called the
shift of the ages which the indigenous
people of a country yeah yeah actually
have representation within the
governance yeah that's that's ridiculous
that that doesn't happen one hundred
percent so I think I'm excited about
this but I don't think that this is the
now it's not that it's not a business
opportunity especially in blockchain but
I think that this route will eventually
be replaced by something that's more
simple now there are other systems that
are already emerging that are not trying
to go the thing is like if you want to
take on the battle of and I'm so proud
of him but if you want to take on the
battle good amount of cryptocurrencies
illiberal and merit but no one sees it
as legit no one in the no one in the
traditional nation body will recognize
vit and will recognize liberland because
their one threatened and to for someone
to recognize a new nation really the
only way that happens is if a country
says like if a country agrees on a
country but that's if there's like war
in this country is like I'm like so done
with like this half of this country so
let's just like split it and they're
like yeah like let it we're gone and or
am i less like unify like the only way
that happens the only way you create a
new country is usually war you don't
usually create new countries through
peaceful economics and even if people
start to take yeah it's all rounded in
2015 becomes a little bit or like 2019
or whatever countries get founded it
becomes a little bit difficult to
so-called give once one Domino Falls
yeah lots of dominoes will fall and that
I think there may be some unforeseen
consequences that are that are made
there could be amazing things that come
from this there will be amazing things
but at the same time if little pockets
of land across like this what is a
session in Texas secession and China
secession and yes
the cedra yep it can create some turmoil
which is what the you are saying is
rather than turmoil like here's and
here's the conclusion that I reached
after spending half am I like working
with libertarians and anarchists and
political revolutionaries yeah why not
pursue that's like I mean that's this
whole own story but why not pursue this
path through peace through the peace of
an emergent property that is already
being created and that emergent property
is intentional community because
intentional communities are happening
and that's what that's what they're
doing liberal and no liberal lands the
opposite they're not an intentional
community yeah oh yeah I would say he
wouldn't call that an intentional
community I would say that they're in
and I would so here's the thing and this
is what I've learned after spending five
years working on the difference between
a nation in a community okay there are
First Nations
there are nation-states there nations
there are States and then there are
intentional communities and but here's
what I learned like going down the path
of Nations is a very violent path and
it's a violent pact with a lot of
politics and a lot of danger and if you
become a serious threat to someone who's
afraid like there's a lot of risk
involved in doing something like that
because the institution is a violent
institution so pursuing that path to do
anything other than help provide humans
with greater access to solve a problem
in that path the thing is like if you're
trying to create your own nation and
you're not solving a problem you're
creating a problem you're creating a
problem for the people that are supposed
to accept you and they're like why am I
going to accept this problem it's like
walking into a group of friends and then
like going into their house and like
wrecking it you're like why would I let
this problem back into my house because
that's how they see people that are
saying they're gonna create their own
nation they're like you're not in our
little like nation Club so I would say
that they are as a matter of fact but in
terms of the weight and I'm proud of him
for what he's doing
so what are you trying to do a
libertarian Island
yeah Marsh may not be the best way to
try and push a more just world it's it's
not that it's not the right way I
appreciate how he's trying to do things
but I think that there's a level at
which I appreciate how he and you know
like all of these people that are trying
to create I I advise several projects
who do this like there's a Kingsland
project there's like a co-founded
several of these projects that are have
been trying to do this I've been friends
with a see studying guys for years we
were actually doing an event the other
week and Randy who's like one of the
founders of see said he said I think
I've known you I think I've known you
longer than I've known any person in
this entire room and that's kind of
astounding and I was like yeah that's
amazing um so I've been involved in the
scene for so long but it's like there's
a level at which it's like why are you
going down the path people are taking
resistance resistance yeah and I'm
sitting with the Fijian Island we're
trying to make a libertarian yeah place
there and then fugiens apparently
realized that they would have a
significant their culture would change a
lot with tech billionaire is coming to
Fiji but I think there's a level at
which there so I'm not saying there's
not a way to create a sovereign nation
and I'm not saying people should stop
trying to do that I mean I think that is
incredible and I think if we have a
bunch of people doing this all of the
time it's kind of like this force like
if everyone just starts doing that it's
like oh wow like this is taking over but
I think that the way that's gonna happen
isn't going to be through people
leveraging the incentives in the current
system calling it a nation in and of
itself I think that puts a lot of people
off it's either like people are really
radical like yeah or they're like the
nation thing seems a little bit like
confrontational to me he's polarizing it
is extremely extremely deeply polarized
the other option is these intentional
communities what is the difference
between what liberal land is doing in an
intentional community intention he's
baked inside of a nation their first so
they're it's kind of the difference
between First Nations and nation states
so nation states were it's kind of like
eagle and the Condor prophecy like
nation states created the divide there
was like our land and our people were
harmonious like we distorted the land
and she provided for us and we provided
for each other
then we went through this divide we're
like we split we split off into many sub
nations and sub communities and sub
countries and in that split we we
separated really that the heat the head
from the heart in our decision-making
process and that's the separation of
really like the like the like the I
don't wanna say the illusion but like
the myth of nationalism and the rise of
the nation-state and the actual human
purpose should I should the second that
we put borders up was the second that we
dropped from our heart up to our head
yeah and then started calling people the
other and that became a division and
that's why all the spiritual communities
were so oppressed because the those who
led with their heart were we're
basically on the opposite scale during
that division and so there's I believe
that there's a level at which returning
to the principles of being a nation of
people who aggregate around culture is
far easier than going through like that
I'm not a fighter I am a lover yeah I'm
a lover yeah
and so there's this level at which I
find like all the world a fight for
peace then we have to fight for love no
that's the total oh my gosh like do you
see mother Teresa even specifically said
she would never go to an anti-war
protest because it's like you're
protesting it's like it's like you're
your subjugating the end result you're
like I want peace but I'm gonna like
fight for it like no I mean that's not
how you achieve like but if you want
peace you you you would you'd met it
you'd meditate or be extremely you know
mindful or peaceful and why not but then
if if the push comes to shove and
there's a there's oppressive structural
violence is going you create some peace
sue sue sue okay god I got it so so you
so you're all on the build and create
side of things the more you build and
create peace yes the more it takes over
and if you stop like that's the thing is
like it has to be and I'm the reason why
this is amazing for many different
reasons but it's also because it's it's
a process of creation it's just through
that process being
being deeply not with liberal and
although that and I are very big
supporters of each other being so it
exude here I would exhaust me so talk
about it being involved in that process
because it's so strenuous it's like it's
like asking someone it's like asking
someone to listen to you who's like
mildly deaf and you're like come on you
just keep like trying to get them to
hear you over and over again and they're
like wah wah wah like you should just
stop just stop just stop
I'll stop talking you stop talking just
stop let's just be let's let's let's
just be done with that right now because
that is - that's just no I'm good even
from your understanding of the
differences between how to start up
groups of people that have a similar
decentralized cause that they want to be
a part of the difference between
intentional community and Korean it's a
concept I don't miss this not not for a
bit because it's actually like it's
actually a great leader so not forbid I
think that he just kind of like his
attitude it's like he's kinda I think
laughs things off just keeps going down
his path and he knows who his supporters
are and I mean that is doing really
really really well so I think he has a
good attitude but I think for most
people like that that process is just
like and that's why he's I think doing
the work that he's doing so well is
because he remains I'm actually affected
by the amount of conflict it's like
going into a constant battle and I'm
like I'm not for me I'm like no like I
don't want to fight do I don't want that
all the same thing like don't people
look at culture right now and just don't
people hate culture right now because
people hate some people hate simulation
right some people are jealous of what
you're doing some people are jealous or
hate hating on building a libertarian
nation-state in the middle of Serbian
Croatia but there's a difference between
like having like some digital haters but
like so jealous of your success
crybabies what you're doing is their
launch centralisation me ordered someone
who says you know we could call some
people to like show up at his house with
poisonous food
or one whoever's house was like there's
a difference between someone who's like
I'm insecure and like I'm gonna use my
insecurities to express it on you and
someone who's like yeah like I could
kill them yeah yeah that's right and so
that's the whole like that's different
and this is what I mean is like taking
this path of like like if this person
proves to be a threat not for him let's
definitely nowhere near project that on
him for like other like it's like if
this person proved to be a threat and
that's like how casually stuff like that
is like it even more casual than that or
sometimes in secret but it will be put
on someone that's trying to start an
intentional community or no not
intentional community this is it's the
opposite like don't please please please
don't don't connect those two because
that's the whole yeah is like a 10
person house in the middle of a city in
the United States that has a similar
value system that all wants some sort of
a peace amongst each other and it's a
please grow their food and proper and
they have their own little events at
their place and yeah so okay so okay so
you're so you so you think that finding
intentional communities then is a
peaceful solver of the crisis of
centralization and borders it's just
that that's like the difference is that
this is like it's like at times it feels
like you're you're rubbing your body up
a sandpaper Mountain wearing a sandpaper
suit also made of made of there's and
there's also velcro buying both pieces
of sandpaper so it's like yeah you know
what I mean it's like but not in a way
that's like beneficial like the
sandpaper is deteriorating the velcro
like in a way that just is like it's
like a mountain of friction well you're
basically going against hundreds of
thousands of years of human it's not
possible it's just that why would you
like difficult it's it's yeah it's not
that it's not possible and I want stuff
like this like I want more people
allowed to that question than that I
asked though do you have that
intentional communities around the world
would be a solution to all of the nation
states borders it's way easier to build
an intentional community than it is to
build a nation I can go out and buy five
thousand acres of land and
I want to live peacefully with this
group of people like away from that
stuff and we're gonna grow our own food
and have our own land and we're gonna
make our own nation of people and we're
all gonna co-create together and we're
gonna have a healthy community that can
be locally managed and we can you know
resolve conflict easily because it's a
smaller group of us and we can all live
in a way that encourages us to be more
social to heal more to talk more to be
more connected with each other to share
more resources rather than hoarding
resources in the community as a dispute
with another community so dispute
resolution is a process that we are also
like it's a core process of the protocol
that we're to paint dispute resolution
restoration so rather than saying like
let's get super aggressive and like say
like we have a dispute and like the
winner of this dispute gets the most
that's how the legal system works now
it's like we fight and I win because I
get the most but the end result should
not be I get the most I win the end
result shouldn't be leveled as a
zero-sum game the end result should be
okay here's a dispute in order to
dissolve we need to actually restore
this situation we need to figure out the
most effective way to restore the
situation and so um yeah it's just
there's this you know we haven't even
gotten into the no life after death or
any of that I wouldn't but yeah there
this this this tangent at us in a very
important direction actually because I
don't think we we have yet to highlight
what completely decentralized both
intentional communities and libertarian
states like liberland
will look like like what they're going
through in order to try and make
something that's not a nation state that
needs a military that they are they are
centralization they are their own nation
it's just whether or not they're
perceived as an accredited nation based
on the number of member states that
validate them and I think in addition to
that there's a level at which global
identity is going to become a process of
the way that we relate to community more
than it's going to become a process of
the way that we perceive ourselves
perceive ourselves as a part of the myth
of national
and so my whole my whole point in this
is that the incentives are still the
same if you're still playing in the
nation-state game the incentives are I
need a horde resources so we can be seen
as a nation or I need to do this like
you're still why play in the same
incentive matrix as a group of people
that have murdered their own citizens
are basically geared on violence and
destruction and exploitation of our
planet it's like I don't want to play it
listen like when you're like playing
with people on a playground like
everyone's playing the game together and
I have to be frank and that there are
ways like there are good people and
there are ways to create structures and
protocols from within those systems to
help better the quality of human life
but going into those systems in a way
that's against them it's kind of like
playing on like it's kind of like
playing ball with a group of like people
that are all not all but there's a lot
of people that are genuinely terrorists
from in that group even from inside the
megalomaniacs there's a lot of issues so
it's like I don't I don't want to be I
don't want to it's not like I don't mean
to be rude but I don't want to play I
think a lot of the time we have very
spiritual people that come on to talk to
us that are levels
advanced in terms of their connection to
earth and other humans but they're so
far advanced in the timeline of things
that they can't figure out how to bring
it to the most relatable forms of
execution today that can help guide
people in that direction in the long
term so I just urge us to work on that
because stuff like this seems like it's
going in somewhat of the right direction
but like you also said there was some
that was a little bit like heavy on
people being upset and whatnot but wide
like the whole point is like it's like
going in the right direction for a group
of people but like generally what I'm
saying is that there's something like
really people love the idea it's really
sexy to say we're gonna create a nation
and go up against the system but I'm not
interested in working on what's sexy
just because it's sexy I'm interested on
actually helping people I'm not
interested in having the most money or
having the most things or having the
most resources or having the strongest
military
I'm interested in helping people live
healthier happier lives
yes and so in doing that I am creating
technology that's not based on branding
something the thing is like I have to be
frank in that like the Buckminster
Fuller quote like there's just a smarter
not and I don't want to say there's a
smarter way to do this like I'm pointing
at vit stuff because the humans earth
civilization design we are super on the
same page and we talk about the what now
the question is how do you go from the
hundreds of thousands of years of
evolution of humanity did the 2018 point
that we're at now how do you aim to
redesign civilization in the year 2019
now that we're entering most effectively
to actually get to that point of peace
love understanding moving forward and
getting past the megalomaniacs and the
corruption the greed and so figuring out
what to build is just most important to
actually get there one of the most
important things we didn't get a touch
on Universal earned-income but I think
this is a crazy important thing that
you've started bringing up rather than
distributing $1,000 per person per month
instead have some sort of an incentive
for them to earn that thousand dollars
every single month what would that look
like oh man I kind of wish we would have
taken a totally different conversation
trajectory because I feel like I just
had to expend all of this energy that's
right and I feel like I had to expend
all this energy in this direction that
I'm like I don't even like there's no
there's no part of me that wanted to go
down that energetic path okay let's
let's let's go let's go let's go if we
don't want to go to Universal
earned-income we can also go to the I
agree that was a lot of energy we can
also go to youth the thoughts on death
as well on the way well or rather that
we don't actually die but that universal
earned income is basically the idea that
the future it's like I feel like talking
about the nation thing is like zeroing
in on like this one little niche thing
it's like it's like being it's like
looking at the world with blinders on
it's like we're only seeing this
one thing when it's like actually that's
not the opportunity right like this is
not the opportunity to redesign the way
the world works because you're still
gonna have to play with the world that
doesn't work so you have to we're gonna
rip off the blinders to actually focus
on building a world that works instead
of focusing all of our time on creating
revolution for the one that doesn't even
if that's all like if there's a lot of
rage or feelings tied up in that like
there's just a smarter way to actually
do things there's a smarter way to
design civilization so let's focus on
smarter solutions then spending our time
on the ideas that may appear to be like
the that may appear to be like really
like you know really what's the word I'm
looking for yeah I mean ideas that look
like they're interesting but actually
like if you look at what's just
interested or like ideas that are like
triggers let's not focus our time on the
things that traumatically trigger us to
say oh yeah like the nation sucks like
let's do that let's actually spend our
time removing the blinders and like
letting go of that trauma to focus
enough on building a world that works
rather than spending our time trying to
fight against and within the one that
doesn't to change it it's like changing
someone who refuses to go to rehab or to
therapy you're like I can't help you if
you refuse to help yourself and that
system is beyond there's there's that
system is beyond in so many ways the
point of us being able to help it right
we can we can do some things to help
humanity
maybe from around it but that system is
is past the point of it's past that
point he drink and be merry
yeah that exactly and justing so you can
get through a process of spiritual self
work that if people took that on first
and foremost then we took on doing a
global globalized decentralized platform
of exchanging value and exchanging
resource flows and building that that's
a global view on things that's a you
know first work on me then work on us in
a decentralized way rather than all the
nitty-gritty Zone in on this one thing
yeah I hear you but it was still
important to unpack the Darius's between
what he's doing and intentional
communities and and the libertarian
states yep can you give us the quick
universe so I'm working on designing a
few different things like whether their
housing models are access models and I
can get deeper into this with the actual
platform the next time that we come on
but it's basically the idea that if you
look at the amount of homes in San
Francisco that are unoccupied it's like
I mean maybe 30% of homes are under
why'd you think 30 I think not just
buildings that are unoccupied because
they haven't been leased out or things
like that but you know landlords I mean
I'm actually just talking about the
percentage of people in San Francisco
who are in technology and spend like two
months out of the year maybe three maybe
maybe four just like traveling around
the world like being out of the country
and who have enough money so that I
don't really want to think about by
doing the Airbnb thing they're like I
don't really need an extra four K like
I'm good and and also the the group of
people who are like people who are
extremely wealthy from India or China or
a country where they say I have two
passports I've been six months of the
year in America and six months of the
year in India or China where you know
Saudi Arabia and so they buy these super
expensive apartments but then they leave
and no one uses them for six months and
and same use case with a number of
landlords in San Francisco that have
purchased like four they've just took a
strong hold on real estate but then they
just keep the house empty and so why are
we not actually effectively leveraging
the use of those resources like Airbnb
doing a program that says if you know
you were affected by the California
wildfires then you can you have these
people who have willingly volunteered
you to stay at their Airbnb for free
mm-hmm and so programs that essentially
say like I'm looking at doing this model
in Puerto Rico
and because it has the its you know as a
state as a state in the United States
technically and I don't want to say it
like that because there's obviously so
much cultural and collective trauma
around that and I really don't want
anyone to feel like in saying that that
I am lessening the value of cultural
sovereignty for a nation that has
basically been oppressed and colonial
eyes because I certainly don't mean it
that way I merely mean that looking at
the spectrum if you're comparing Puerto
Rico to the other 50 states they've had
more foreclosures than any other state
in the entire United States like 27
percent I think like there's a forty
seven percent total foreclosure like
they were experiencing like 13
foreclosures a day and then the
hurricane and so there's like the same
thing that happened with the mortgage
bubble basically you had all these
people from Wall Street going in and
buying Puerto Rican mortgages and
knowing that people couldn't pay and
then having homes foreclosed upon and so
there is this huge issue of not only
properties being destroyed but of
properties being you know they're just
being this like endless cycle of
systemic exploitation and so because
there's such a high rate of foreclosures
going into a community like this and
saying okay whether this building is
like foreclosed or it's let's say it's
like an abandoned school but a habitable
property abandoned school abandoned
apartment building abandoned Church
let's take this habitable property and
actually make it livable
it's habitable let's make it livable
let's make it comfortable there's some
more that's doing that in the abandoned
warehouses in areas like Detroit right
now
exactly very interesting like they grow
Canada they're trying to grow cannabis
and have like maker spaces and have
people live there and also that kind of
interesting stuff yes and so it's the
idea of saying that let's take these
habitable structures and let people live
in them for free so long as they're
actively contributing to their community
so let's say like the city of San
Francisco spends thirty million dollars
cleaning up needles and feces every year
well you could actually have people go
through and accomplish tasks from the
city to live in housing for free and so
the city could cut back on their budget
by having labor given to people that are
already living in homes that are owned
by the city it's really simple it's
actually a really simple idea like if
the city or private sector or whoever
already owns property
let's have the person who owns that
property assign different systems of
tasks to people so you can actually earn
that income through engaging in a
process of incentivized civic
responsibility okay my civic
responsibility okay so this is for those
that want a universal earned income yeah
so it's not just given to everybody but
rather this is a civic engagement you
can get earned income that way so it's
like it's kind of like a city job of
doing something specifically that's
important engaging with your communities
interesting and then earning income and
earning housing as well yeah you were in
access and the other so I mean
specifically for San Francisco what I
posited is that the amount of cafeteria
waste that happens from yet in Google
Facebook like every major tech company
here if you were able to give people
training programs that could allow them
to have jobs and and just bill whether
it's like a series of tiny homes like
there are many different ways that this
model can be executed but the foundation
of the thesis is granting access for
incentivize civic responsibility and
whether that's access to economics
education housing food all of the above
every basic resource that you would need
it's providing access in a model that's
actually incentivizing accomplishment
and thus providing greater education
greater opportunity greater skill in the
workforce for people all over and for
training programs for companies to
actually put people into like a pre
staffing process before they're even
hired and and I think there's a way to
and it's not only through housing there
are many different ways that the
universal income Universal earned income
can and will play out but I think that
we're shifting more toward that
primarily because basic income you don't
value something really if someone just
gives it to you for free you might take
that thousand dollars would be oh cool
like now I'm going to get an extra TV a
month but not really change my life
circumstances we need to enable people
to be put in communities and situations
that can create a standard for them to
uphold themselves to that can encourage
them to change the way they live and to
be more inspired and to be more free and
meaning for themselves in life and maybe
university
can come when to help people find
meaning left maybe would help people
find meaning LIF maybe earned income
sorry way to go what do you think about
death what were your thoughts here that
you wanted to share we love talking
about death yeah we because there's like
this avoid pre-birth and there's a void
post death that and then everything in
between is life and then it's kind of
interesting what goes on on the other
sides yeah so yeah I mean my East's on
this and this is obviously a way longer
Congress I think we actually have a
podcast about this that hasn't been
released yeah yeah my my real thesis on
my real thesis on death is that we don't
die I don't believe that we actually die
and there are many different levels at
which that takes shape and form but
there is an energy that we carry through
us in life it's the same energy that I
was talking about earlier today what
flows through you and what you carry and
what you admit and that that energy
although it can take many different
shapes and forms and personalities that
energy is a form of matter and it cannot
be created or destroyed actually asked a
very prominent Buddhist I said well what
happens to life if it does not
reincarnate and he in meditation without
saying anything directed my attention to
a lady bug crawling on the ground and
directed my attention to the grass
growing in between the folds of concrete
and said the energy goes back to all
forms of life hmm and so there's a level
at which we are both all in this
together
but the process like it's that pulse
mm-hmm that exists whether we do or not
but we're all part of it because the
pulse that lives in our physical body is
not merely a post that exists in us it
is a pulse that is representative of
everything that is of all that is and
that we exist regardless of this pulse
because we live in that one mm-hmm the
pulse of all that is includes us
individually and we live in that pulse
of all that is so therefore there is no
life and death there just is all that is
it's so difficult to get this I love the
idea of a pulse though of you know the
Egyptians had no word for death they
called the process of dying that the
soul would be walking and that our soul
was merely walking from this life into
the next life and whether we choose to
walk and be a human or there are some
people who might want to become
completely formless and just become a
part of the earth there are some people
who may transcend and become a part of
all that is and there are those of us
who stay as Bodhisattvas participating
in the cycle
and hopefully bringing more humans out
of the samsaric wheel that is life one
thing I know for sure is that I know
nothing I love you Tony Lane this has
been super fun this is it is super fun
we didn't even really get to talk much
about ancient civilizations besides what
you just said about that we have I was
gonna say there will be plenty of words
yes plenty more conversations with Tony
on the show to actually be able to talk
about this I'll close out and then we'll
have Tony sing our sing our way out it
was really profound learning about
spiritual bypass as an individual like
that spiritual bypass where is that miss
lemon why do you close the show and then
start the show back up again and how do
you do that I don't understand why it
wasn't it wasn't really I don't close
the show and then start what it was wrap
it up that's not what it was all right
one time what's gonna sting that's all
it was much love to you everyone thank
you for tuning in we greatly appreciate
him looking forward to your comments
below you'll be exciting to hear what
you think about all of the different
nuance that was talked about also go and
check out Tony's work in the comments
below all of it's down there go follow
her and Ron thanks for producing and
directing everyone much love go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world we love you all
all right and let's get that beautiful
voice on the way out I never had a dream
come true till the day that I found you
even though
moved on you'll always be my baby I
never found the words to say you're the
one I think a bystander where life takes
me to a part of me will always be with
you
[Music]
you
and one more I just want to finish the
first song and when I knew I'd be
looking at the moon
but I'd be seeing
Oh